[Music]
one of the key ideas of stoic philosophy
an idea that is incredibly helpful in
day-to-day life is the distinction that
Epictetus makes early on in his
enchiridion between what is in our
control and what is not in our control
I'm really excited to tell you about a
free webinar and two online seminars
that we have coming up in this month of
may 2017 on that very topic
I'm Greg Sadler I'm the president of
reason i/o which is a company devoted to
not only putting philosophy into
practice but also disseminating
philosophical ideas and enabling people
to understand difficult philosophical
text thinkers and topics worldwide I'm
also the editor of stoicism today and
somebody who has been studying teaching
about and practicing stoic philosophy
for quite some time so this is going to
be a set of online events that you're
definitely not going to want to miss
we've been offering full online courses
in the reason IO Academy and we're going
to be rolling out a lot more of those
this year but my viewers subscribers
students followers whatever you want to
call them in this great online world
have been asking for more events like
these things that they could attend and
get a lot out of in a short period so
we've been offering free 45-minute
webinars and much more intensive
two-hour long online seminars this month
as I said it's about epictetus and what
we call the dichotomy of control that's
the topic that we're going to be
exploring also talk a little bit more
about stoic philosophy in general so if
you don't have a background in stoicism
you don't have to worry about it and
we'll go into a number of different
topics that are that are connected with
it so what are we going to cover in the
webinar and then more intensively in the
online seminars well first of all
to talk about what Epictetus and the
Stoics in general think is indeed in our
control something that we have not only
power over but responsibility for and
those things that lie outside of our
control and we'll talk quite a bit about
the consequences which tend to be kind
of bad for us in confusing these two
categories we'll also go a little bit
more into detail about what it is that
that Epictetus does think it is in our
control including this term prior ASIS
or faculty choice that he sees at the
core of the person our emotions our
beliefs our desires our versions and
then we'll talk about the things that he
says lie outside of our control what the
Stoics call externals or indifference
and that will lead quite naturally into
some challenges or some objections to
this this whole idea because the Stoics
say things that are pretty paradoxical
like our bodies are not in our control
our finances are not in our control and
so we'll have to do a little bit of talk
at that well to what degree are they
this will lead naturally into a new
proposal that was put forth by William
Irvine who wrote a great book about
stoicism several years back saying that
maybe we should think about it not in
terms of by dichotomy of control but a
trichotomy of control this sort of 2/3
and we'll look at his proposal and
whether it works well or not and then
we'll talk about what epictetus himself
specifically has to say about you know
the things and the dimensions that are
in our control there are some external
things which themselves are not in our
controller where outcomes aren't in our
control but our use or how we deal with
them is epic team says that is in our
control and that happens to be very
important and we'll finish by talking
about how we might expand or in some
ways consolidate what is in our control
so we can have a life that's more free
more happy a life of flourishing as the
Stoics conceived of it at this point
you're probably asking yourself
three important questions when where and
how when are these online events where
do they actually meet and how do I sign
up for them so let me start with the
where we use freeconferencecall.com
which is a video conferencing platform
and we have our own meeting space which
you'll jump into if you participate in
either of these kinds of events now the
when very important and and I do want to
preface this by saying not only do you
want to mark your calendar you also want
to check your time zone because all of
the times that we're giving are for
central time that is Chicago time that's
the time zone that I'm in so May 16th
which is a Tuesday at 12:00 p.m.
running from 12 p.m. to 12:45 p.m. it is
the free webinar anybody can participate
in that we can have as many participants
as we can we can you know find but you
know you do want to have questions ready
ahead of time and then the online
intensive seminars we actually have two
of these I should mention as well these
are not different from each other
they're just different times we have
those on Saturday May 20th one starts at
10 a.m. and runs to 12 p.m. the other
one starts at 4:00 p.m. and runs to 6
p.m. again Central Time now why do we
have two of these well we only have 12
seats available for each of them because
we want this to be a much more intensive
and intimate experience getting to
interact and and talk about these issues
we try to keep them as budget friendly
as possible so enrollment in those
online seminars is $49 the webinar is
completely free of course and you might
want to check out the webinar just to
get a taste to see if you might be
interested in the seminars I'm very
excited to teach and talk about this
this great material with you Epictetus
is one of my favorite philosophers as a
matter of fact I'll even put a link
below to a interview that I did
I said that Epictetus is discourses is
one of the three books that most changed
my life
a little bit of a digression there in
any case check out the the descriptions
check out the links sign up for these
events seats are going to go quick I
think for the online seminars because
there is such a massive interest in
stoic philosophy at this time and I look
forward to seeing you there
[Music]